so an interesting study came out from
UCLA studying Sood student social skills
related to smartphones and all this
technology so it's a little technical
here so I'm gonna read it the UCLA
psychology department looked at two
groups of 11 to 12 year olds half the
students spent five days at a nature and
science camp where digital technology
was strictly taboo could not do any of
this the participants were forced to
interact with each other talk
face-to-face it was crazy it was
old-school they were all shown
photographs of people and asked to state
whether the emotions expressed in the
photographs were happy sad angry or
frightened they were then shown videos
and asked to describe what was happening
in the simple scenarios okay I think you
could follow along there now let's look
at the findings during the research one
group made significantly more progress
than the other the group deprived of all
digital media even television performs
significantly better at recognizing
emotions than those who allowed to keep
texting and tweeting and talking on
Facebook after just five days I've got a
quote from the researcher he said many
people are looking at the benefits of
digital media in education and not many
are looking at the cost decreased
sensitivity to emotional cues losing the
ability to understand the emotions of
other people is one of the cost so let's
stop there for a second let's just talk
about that now we just did the segment
on iPhones and the addiction to this
thing and all that I see this every day
in life every day I'm walking around and
I admit you guys know how much I tweet
so I'm not putting it out there and I'm
dude we're doing this on YouTube and
we're all on Facebook and all that but I
see this constantly now people walking
down walking like this literally
crashing into [ __ ] people this you're
talking to someone literally making eye
contact with them and saying something
important and then they immediately and
then just in middle they just start
doing this talking to my daughter it
looks like yeah how old you got it with
they're both well one is 23 yeah and the
other one is 19 okay so they're a little
a little ahead of these in age but
certainly younger than well have used I
mean do you see this every day in your
life this endless like lack of attention
people forgetting things you can you can
you feel it at a social setting which
you know but three of us have been
together
but you know when we're all like the
phones are away and it's everything and
we're just connecting and it's really
great everything in the minute one
person takes yes the phone out it gives
permission to everyone else of the thing
like okay I'll check the email and now
there's like a silence comes over and
you can feel the disconnect and then
when everyone puts it away it takes a
moment to like oh we were reading like
this the it's the whole nother part of
the animal mind comes forward of oh okay
that's right connection social cues yeah
it's I find that to be just the energy
that happens in a room that's just the
shift around people around that I
fascinating yeah we did a story on how
it literally is rewiring people's brains
because you're not supposed to be
inundated with information constantly
and we're actually changing how we I
just heard a social scientist talk about
this on another show and he said you
know actually evolution of this kind of
stuff yes is a rewiring of the brain but
a real evolution takes about a thousand
years for the species just be speeding
it up because I've seen that type of
studies too and that maybe they don't
think so I mean in the short term it's
definitely affecting things but it's not
actually evolving but you know we'll see
it's honestly true story my daughter
just went back down to school for her
second year of college because I have
money to grow I mean I I literally in
the way into the studio I was just Chuck
and fives everybody I walked by so we're
talking and it's you know I'm very much
the daddy-daughter thing you know it's
like okay well this is your second year
and you know I know you're switching
majors and like literally a four
sentences in brought up the phone and
you know looked at me and was like and I
it was all I could do
it's all I could be well to not just
start beating her to death with the
phone which is why the 5.5 iPhone is
really gonna work for me because like I
can do it in less hits it's just it's a
part of their Norman culture I have a
picture of the same kid you want an iMac
the original the one that was like a
like an old TV with you know mousing
around on some game some learning game
some Mavis Beacon teaches typing
[ __ ] she's like five with the bottle
her like bottle and she's just like
yeah it we've lost this generation to
whatever this digital nightmare is I
mean it's a nightmare that they are so
easily and we almost cured a Dede and
then the Apple helped us break it but
it'll be fascinating because I think
what'll come into the culture and
there'll be a new need in the culture is
people to create space and circumstance
and opportunity and teach people to have
emotional intelligence again which I'm
excited about because that's what I love
to do that is your thing